d'abord c'était un gros travail ça tout
le monde le reconnaît
c'était un véritable baroudeur si je
peux lire de l'information de
l'information sportive notamment parce
que camille était sur tous les fronts
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas de domaine sur
le plan sportif qu'il ne connaissait pas
et dans laquelle ils n'étaient aveu
n'est pas s'il pouvait être sur tous les
terrains à la fois et en même temps je
crois qu'il le il le ferait mais ce
conte
c'est moins de cas mais alexandre c'est
que j'avais plein d'humour ainsi chacun
se souvienne de cette fameuse boutade du
volley vacances il s'agissait vous vous
souvenez de
lors d'un ton six pistes de la
martinique
il avait dit que aventure ballet était
un véritable vol vacances a tellement il
y avait des coureurs qu'elle était
rescapé donc et puis et puis il faut se
souvenir que c'est bien en période de
toute façon et que les obsèques de mme
aval après raymond calix c'est lui qui
avait pris la relève mais je préfère
citer secada parce que d'autres vont
parler de lui en tant que rédacteur
sportif c'est surtout ce qu'on va
retenir mais moi je préfère retenir
cette partie là